Okay, welcome back to video number 10. If
you recall in video number 9, we were
getting perspective on global GDP, and in
particular, United States GDP. And our
view on global GDP, we discovered is
really going to dictate our positioning in
our portfolio for indexes like the S&P
500,
the FTSE 100, the FTSE 100. But it also
dictates our positioning not only in
indexes within the stock market, but also
within currencies, commodities, and
interest rates, or bonds. Now, we're going
to move on to actually predicting GDP. And
given that the United States GDP is the
most important, by far, we are going to
start looking at what we call leading
indicators that predict
GDP in the future. Now, your job as a
trader really is to predict the future.
You want to be in a situation where you're
using the market now as a proxy for your
expectations in the future. And this is
what professional traders do. The first
thing we're going to do is define what a
leading indicator is, and then we're going
to move on to the most important one,
which is the ISM, the Institute for Supply
Management Report on Business.
Sometimes called the PMI, sometimes called
the PMI, the Purchasing Managers Index.
Now, the ISM is very, very important. And
it's also extremely useful, not just for
predicting GDP, but also for deciding what
to buy and sell within the manufacturing
industry.
Because we get some qualitative clues from
the ISM every month that tells us which
industries are growing the most and which
industries are contracting. Therefore, we
can get clues of which way to be
positioned. So it really tells us two
things. It tells us the expectation of GDP
in the United States in the future, but
for now, therefore, we can use the index
to represent our view at this stage for a
prediction of GDP in the future.
But also in the qualitative statement, we
can also use the ISM to discover what we
can actually go out and buy and short
within our portfolio and within the United
States.
Now, the ISM is widely, even by
professional traders, it's widely
misunderstood and misinterpreted. If you
do a bit of work and do a bit of digging,
you'll realise that historically, the ISM
is extremely important and an incredible
indicator for predicting GDP and deciding
what to buy and short. So without further
ado, why don't we go over to the
presentation and I'll see you at the end
of the video with a summary.
So how do we predict GDP?
There's businesses and consumers, the
private sector. There's a private and the
public sector, but the private sector is
made up businesses and consumers. And
within businesses, there's just two
different types of manufacturing and
services. And within both, you've got
cyclicals and defensives.
That tell us what's going to tell us
what's going to happen in the
manufacturing industry.
First one, Institute for Supply
Management, ISM, Manufacturing Reports on
Business or Purchasing Managers Index.
It's a well known indicator in the US, but
people don't use it enough. And there's
tons of information in there for you to
make money.
It gets released on the first business
day. It gets released on the first
business day of each month. And the URL is
there. So you can even just Google it and
you'll find it straight away.
Essentially, what is it? A survey of 300
US manufacturing companies in the US. And
it's related to their business activity in
the previous month, covering five areas.
It represents 20% of the US economy. So
why do we look at it? Because the other
80% is services. So why do we look at
manufacturing first? Why do we place a bit
more importance on it?
You can guess. Well, you get more data
because services only goes back to the
late 70s. So you get more significance
over more business cycles.
So we're going to look at an ISM report
from a few years ago. We're going to look
at the ISM report of September 2010. And
at this time, QE measures have been
announced in the United States for QE2.
And they were starting to actually print
money in September. So it was announced in
May to start in September.
The survey is equally weighted across five
areas. So the purchasing managers at each
of the manufacturing companies is asked a
series of questions on the five areas that
you're looking at now.
So in the last month, what are you seeing
in new orders, up or down? Production, is
it up or down? Are you planning on hiring
more people in the future?
Deliveries, up or down? And inventories,
up or down? If you've got a warehouse full
of widgets, if you're really, really
bullish on the future, what do you do?
You fill your warehouse full of more
widgets. If you're really, really bearish
on the future, what do you do?
You de-stock. You try to get all of your
stock out the door. So you've got an empty
warehouse. That's just the basics of
inventories.
So let's have a look at what it looks like
when it comes out, and how you actually
interpret it, and how you trade off the
back of it.
The headline number is reported there, the
PMI, 54.4. Remember this is September
2010. Basically, the headline number,
every number that you're looking at, is a
percentage number.
If it's above 50%, it means it's growing.
If it's under 50%, it means it's
contracting. So growing on the previous
month, contracting on the previous month.
Yeah. So what does that tell us? Well, the
PMI, the headline number is 54.4. And in
the previous month, it was 56.3.
So 1.9% change. It's growing, because it's
reported to be above 50, which means it's
growing. But it's growing at a slower
rate.
And we've had 14 months of the trend,
which is growing. So 14 months above 50.
Make sense?
So take 14 months of September 2010, what
do we get to? Sorry? July 2009.
July 2009. What do we know about that time
period? When did the US come out of a bear
market?
December 2010. So this started telling you
18 months before that the US was going to
come out of a bear market.
Because the manufacturing industries were
reporting growth for the first time, 14
months previous to that.
It's pretty significant.
So what would have happened if you'd have
bought the stock market in July 2009?
When you saw this, for the first time, go
above 50? Because the months previous to
that, there was a year of reporting of
construction.
So what level would you have bought the
stock market at in July 2009?
What?
Let's go back to the charts. Let's have a
look.
There.
That's just you saying the ISM is growing
for the first time in months and months
and months.
So the US manufacturing industry has just
started reporting some growth for the
first time in over a year.
Well, longer. It was over two years. So
you just go, I'm buying the S&P 500.
Is it hard?
So what would you have bought it at? You
have bought it at 900.
And what do you think stocks that were
part of that index, some of them would
have outperformed?
And some of them would have
underperformed. So some stocks, so the
stock market goes from 900 to, let's say,
1200, 300 points.
There'll be some stocks that tripled. Just
that one indicator.
Incidentally, let's have a look at this
again. Where did the stock market bottom?
Anybody know what that was then?
It's quite well known. The trading, yeah,
the trading low of the S&P 500 was 666 in
the first week of March 09.
Now let's connect the dots here before we
even look at the ISM.
What do we think the bottom of the ISM
was?
The bottom of the ISM was February 09.
And then when it was reported on the first
business day of March 09, the March
number,
it contracted at a slower rate for the
first time.
And then the market bottomed.
Because everybody bought their shorts back
saying, okay, the business cycle has been
now bottomed.
That was it. That was the bottom of the
market, March 09.
And you get all of the other, you can see
the contributions of the different parts
of the ISM.
So how much is new orders contributing?
How much is production contributing?
You start to learn what's going on. You
learn what's going on in the US economy
when you look at every report.
That's what it looks like going back to
1947.
And when you look at the ISM, what you're
actually looking at there is the business
cycle of the United States.
What do you think will happen if we put on
the right-hand axis GDP growth in
percentage terms going back to 1947?
What would it look like?
Same but with a lag.
So we zoom in a little bit there.
Actually, I think we do 1972.
So we do the last 30 or 40 odd years.
That's the ISM on the right-hand axis and
percentage real GDP growth in the United
States, year on year.
It's the business cycle.
ISM against GDP 1972.
So what happens, the ISM just, when the
ISM goes down, 12 months later the GDP
number is contracted.
When the ISM goes up, 12 months later the
GDP number is reported as expanding.
So by the time GDP is out its old news,
it's irrelevant.
Because the market has moved and you've
participated in the move and made money.
It's a very powerful indicator for
actually representing your view on the
world and then using indices, commodities,
currencies and rates to express that view.
If you do it like that and nothing else,
and you're right between 67% and 93% of
the time, you're going to be very wealthy
in your life.
And I know the guys that came last time
when we did the interview here, I try not
to measure anything relative.
But, so in absolute terms, you should make
money all the time if you do that.
And you don't even have to trade every
day.
You can trade once a month.
You can trade once a quarter.
Just buy the S&P 500 for the next six
months.
Just leave it.
If that's what you think.
Yeah.
That's fine.
If you make money, you make money.
But if you do it in up markets and down
markets, where you're going long and
short, and you do it for the rest of your
life,
you're going to make more money than
everyone else.
So over time, you're going to get
relatively wealthier to everybody else in
the world.
Because what happens to all the funds that
have pensions?
When the stock market halves.
Their pension halves.
But what do you do?
You double your money.
So you get four times wealthier.
You get four times wealthier than a
recession.
So when the ISM is above 50, it's
basically saying 12 months from now, the
US economy will be growing.
Whether it's at a slower pace, that's
fine.
You find that out at the time.
But if it's just above 50, in a year, it's
growing.
Therefore, S&P 500 returns are likely to
be positive.
More than likely.
So you're basically predicting the
one-on-one situation.
You're buying the market now in
anticipation of, say, a 20% move up in the
stock market in the next 12 months.
That's why you're doing it now.
Because if you don't, but if you do, when
GDP comes out, you've missed the
opportunity.
When it goes below 50, the US economy is
contracting.
And S&P 500 returns are likely to be
negative in the next 12 months.
So you're trying to predict the zero-zero
situation.
S&P 500 falls and GDP falls in the next
year.
And when the ISM peaks, what does it mean
when it peaks and drops?
Well, let's have a look at the chart.
When the ISM peaks, we're trying to
predict the zero-one situation.
That's a peak.
That's a trough.
So when it peaks, you're trying to predict
the zero-one, where the expectations of
the markets
have become too high in the short term,
because the reality is that the economy is
forecasted to grow.
Therefore, S&P 500 should go out, but
maybe not by as much as everybody
previously thought.
So you take profits.
Make sense?
It's not rocket science.
I'm not from NASA.
So how to follow the ISM?
If it's above 50 and growing, you've got a
strong bias towards being long the stock
market.
If it's above 50 and slowing, you've got a
weak bias to be long, and there's nothing
wrong
with being market neutral or flat.
You don't have to participate.
If it's above 50 and slowing, you've got a
strong bias for being short.
If it's above 50 and growing, you've got a
weak bias for being short, and there's
nothing wrong with being market neutral or
flat.
You do not have to participate.
One negative about professional traders is
that they always feel that they have to
participate.
Retail traders, you don't.
Professional traders have pressure from
the external shareholders of the bank to
hit targets every three months so the bank
makes money in their earnings and beats
the previous quarter.
You don't have to do that.
Hedge fund investors put pressure on the
hedge fund manager to outperform and hedge
against inflation all the time.
So they always have to participate.
As a retail trader, you don't have to.
So you're actually in a luxurious position
where you can be long for three years, and
then when the ISM peaks, you just say, do
you know what?
Can't be bothered.
Just trade out of everything.
Take the money you've made in the last
three years, I go live on a beach for a
year and come back when the ISM bottoms
out again.
It's perfect.
Retail traders have fantastic freedom.
That's why I enjoy what I do so much,
because I can leave and just go on holiday
for 50 days if I want.
That's why.
Ism peaks above 50.
Short, so slowing for the first time in a
long time.
So that peak, yeah.
Short, with a weak bias, market neutral or
flat.
Go to the beach.
Ism troughs below 50, so growing for the
first time.
Sorry, not growing, the contraction
slowing down.
Long, with a weak bias, but you can also
be market neutral or flat.
So when do you get strong biases?
When it's above 50 and growing, when it's
below 50 and contracting.
That's very strong bias, yeah?
All the stuff in between, you don't have
to participate, but you'll have a weaker
bias to be either way.
Yeah?
But when you get hold of the notes, and
this goes, this is the last 13 years,
well, 12 years.
And it's just charting what you probably
were thinking at the time.
So there's no rule book where you say you
have to do this at every level of the ISM.
But what it does do is map out the thought
process of what you should probably be
thinking of doing
when you see the ISM doing certain things.
Like lessons that we've learned from the
last decade, and lessons from 1947 to
present day.
So just mapping those thought processes of
how you input the decision-making process
into your portfolio.
But this is just one indicator.
So it's reporting monthly.
We obviously don't get an update every
day.
But throughout the month, there'll be lots
of indicators that will give us updates.
Some of them will be lagging.
Some of them will be coincident.
Some of them will be leaving.
Lagging indicators we've got no interest
in.
They tell you what happened in the past,
and they confirm or deny what you were
thinking months before.
Coincident indicators tell you what's
happening now, and they confirm or deny
what you were thinking months before.
So the headline in the FT, UK enters
recession, that might be out in a few
weeks' time.
Is that useful to us?
Complete nonsense.
UK enters recession as a headline.
It doesn't do anything for you as a
trader.
It doesn't predict anything.
It just reports the news.
What happened yesterday.
What's probably happening at that time is
that things might be turning,
and people are predicting that in 12
months' time the UK could grow at 2.5%.
So everyone's buying the markets, and the
markets are ripping.
It's completely irrelevant.
And then all the retail traders come in
and short on that headline and get carried
out.
If you go through, do a statistical
correlation of the ISM with a time lag of
12 months,
ISM is 85% correlated to GDP with a
12-month time lag since 1947.
So even though it's now only 20% of the
economy in the United States,
it's still incredibly predictive of what's
going to happen in 12 months' time.
So you can't discount it.
It's got significance over many, many
business cycles.
So we use it as an indicator to tell us
what's going to happen in the US economy
12 months from now with 85% certainty.
And we use the S&P 500 as a discounting
mechanism to express our view.
And we do it now.
And when you're running a portfolio, you
want to be switching your long short bias
and your world view.
You switch your long short bias based on
your world view.
And your world view comes predominantly
from all of your leading indicators.
And the ISM is one of them.
And it's one very important one.
Because it's so predictive of what's going
to happen,
sometimes one measure or one read isn't
enough.
Because you might be too early to a move.
And you might actually, if you're going
too early, you might actually be wrong for
a month or two.
So it's quite good to get into the habit
of waiting for three or four readings to
confirm what's going to happen.
That's when you look at it against S&P 500
percentage returns on an annual basis.
Pretty much exactly the same way.
The new orders part of the ISM is
generally seen by professional traders as
a leading indicator to the ISM itself.
Because it's the most sensitive part of
the report.
So that's new orders against ISM,
production against ISM, employment against
ISM, deliveries against ISM,
Inventories against ISM.
But what's great about the report is, you
also get a qualitative statement.
So every month, they pull out a bunch of
comments that come from the purchasing
managers of the companies themselves.
And they also tell you which industries
within the ISM are growing the fastest,
reporting the most growth,
in order to the ones that are reporting
the least growth.
And you can take clues from the report to
generate trading ideas very, very quickly.
So remember this was in September 2010.
Well, let's have a look at the report.
We've seen manufacturing industries, 13
are reporting growth in September.
What does that tell you straight away?
The majority of them are reporting growth.
That's bullish for GDP in the future.
In what order though?
What's the industry that's reporting the
most growth?
fastest slowdown?
Wood products.
So what essentially is the apparel
industry?
It's consumer discretionary spending.
So non-essential items.
So clothing, but mostly medium and
high-end retailers.
Yeah, apparel.
And what's wood products in the US?
Housing.
It's the timber industry for the
construction industry for the US.
Housing.
What do you think would have happened if
you have gone long the US apparel sector
on September the 2nd, 2010.
And short the wood products sector, as in
the US house builders, in September 2010.
You just put that trade on for three
months, six months.
You'd have made money.
In fact, you would have outperformed.
What about the statements here from
respondents?
So, business results, top and bottom line.
Continue to meet or exceed our operating
plan and exceed prior year performance by
double digits.
That's coming from the chemical products
industry.
So that's a guy who's the purchasing
manager at a chemical products company in
the US.
What's that person actually saying in that
statement?
Read between the lines.
Shall I translate it for you?
From corporate speak into trailer speak.
Hi guys.
The earnings estimates that we gave you
three months ago, we're going to beat
them.
Because our operating plan is beating the
plan that we gave you and we believed was
correct three months ago.
Oh, by the way, we're reporting in
December and it's September, so you should
buy my stock now.
Before I report earnings going up.
You'd have basically made a net return of
74% in eight months.
Not bad.
No insider information required.
And why did they go up, why did you make
74% on that trade?
Because the earnings of Ralph Lauren went
up because GDP was going up and it's a
cyclical stock consumer discretionary.
And PHM, Hult, their earnings were going
sideways or lower and they couldn't
compete in the housing market as a house
builder with all of the inventory that was
on the market.
I.e. developing houses when all the
sub-crime houses had been repossessed and
they were being unwound into the
repossession market.
That's why.
But, what they were telling you was here,
with the manufacturing sector that's
slowing the fastest, relative to everybody
else, they were telling you that there.
All you have to do is connect the dots.
Why are they slowing?
Oh, I see.
Foreclosures.
Simple.
Long, Ralph Lauren, short, hold homes.
74% in eight months.
Can literally be that straight forward.
In terms of rates and spending.
The ISN is used as a significant indicator
by the US Treasury to decide fiscal
spending and by the Federal Reserve to set
interest rates.
If the Federal Reserve and the US Treasury
expect GDP to contract, they reduce rates
now.
So, what else could you have done here?
When you're seeing this, Ralph Lauren,
long, short, hold homes.
And what's happening?
The US Federal Reserve is spanking and
reducing interest rates to zero.
So, quick recap.
It's useful in three ways.
Predicting US GDP to gain a world view.
So, you can actually have an overall view
on the world.
But, it's obviously sensible to go and
have a look at the leading indicators and
apply the same thesis to Eurozone and to
China.
And, you can.
So, you can work out in its entirety what
the world is going to do.
But, the ISN is the most important one
because it's predicting the biggest
economy.
In ten years time, that might be
different.
It might be China PMI.
China PMI is pretty significant now.
Secondly, for predicting stock market
returns.
And, for predicting business trends in a
particular manufacturing sector.
So, what it actually does is when we go on
to the next level tomorrow, which is
industry view.
It's one of the places where you can start
to gain industry views on particular
manufacturing sectors.
To start generating ideas.
Why is wood product slowing the most?
And, then you go and find out.
And, you form a view on the industry.
So, we got four spreadsheets in terms of
downloads that we'll send you.
So, the stuff that you saw there with the
Excel charts.
These.
I can send you the ISM Manufacturing
Index, all the data, going back to 1947
with all the charts.
ISM versus GDP growth, going back to 1947.
ISM versus percentage returns of the S&P
500, going back to 1947.
And, a historical data master summary,
which if you fill out each month.
So, you just have to clear contents and
fill it out.
It tells you what's going to happen.
It's really easy to use.
Okay.
So, welcome back.
I hope you've managed to follow the
presentation there.
And, get a real insight into why the ISM
is so important.
And, I think we've figured out here that
the ISM is very important in two specific
ways.
Firstly, for predicting US GDP.
And, therefore, the potential for global
GDP because of the size of the United
States.
And, if the ISM is very, very good at
predicting GDP, then we're using the S&P
500 as a proxy now.
Now, the reason why the S&P 500, as you
saw in previous videos, predicts GDP with
that time lag of three to six months is
because the ISM is predicting GDP with a
time lag of about 12 months.
With an 85% correlation throughout
business cycles going back to 1947.
And, professional traders are using
leading indicators like the ISM to take
positions now.
And, then the S&P 500 moves.
And, it moves to predict GDP later down
the line.
So, six to 12 months.
So, that's the first thing.
The ISM is very, very useful in that way
for our positioning in our portfolio.
And, our world view.
Our global view.
The second thing that's important about
the ISM is the qualitative statements that
we get from the companies themselves.
Now, looking through the example that we
saw, we can see that in the September
report in 2010, that the apparel companies
and the wood products companies were
giving us clues as to trade ideas that
could occur within our portfolio.
This example was a very good example of
going long a US apparel company and short
a home builder.
Because, what that's actually doing is
predicting the earnings of the companies.
The purchasing managers of those companies
are specifically telling you in those
statements what their earnings are going
to be.
So, the expectations of the market shift.
And, what happens is professional traders
will go long the apparel company now and
short the home builder now.
And, then once the earnings come out,
three, six and nine months down the line.
And, those statements have occurred within
the material change in the earnings.
By the time this is news, the professional
trader has made their money because the
stocks have already moved.
And, what happens later, well, the retail
trader or the uneducated trader comes into
the market and provides liquidity on the
other side for the professional traders to
get out.
So, I think you're starting to get an
appreciation now of the bigger picture and
why it's so important to use leading
indicators to not only predict GDP but
also to potentially predict our
positioning and our positioning in
specific sectors and specific stocks.
So, the ISM comes out every month and you
should diligently go through it and really
understand and interpret what it means.
And, now you've got all the downloads.
You can see from the downloads in video
nine and ten that from the GDP numbers and
from the S&P 500 correlation and from the
ISM correlation with the stock market and
GDP that the ISM absolutely does predict
GDP.
And, therefore stock market returns and it
does this with an 85% correlation through
our business cycles since 1947.
Now, it wouldn't be prudent as a
professional trader only to rely on one
indicator.
I'm not advocating that at all.
You should absolutely back up or look at
other leading indicators throughout each
month and always question your world view.
So, the ISM and other indicators in their
entirety are going to give you a very good
idea, a very clear picture of US GDP 12
months from now but you definitely
shouldn't be relying on one.
You should absolutely be relying on others
as well.
So, if you bring them all into their
entirety then you're going to get a much
clearer picture and the reliability of
your analysis is going to be far greater.
Now, the other thing we saw with the ISM
was positioning and again I'm going to
keep going back to this point.
Unfortunately, there is no rulebook.
The market in 1986 is different to the
market now and the market in 2030 is going
to be different to the market now.
So, when you're looking at the ISM and
saying well I'm going to go long, short or
be market neutral in my portfolio.
Unfortunately, again, there is no rulebook
where you go onto Amazon or go to a
bookstore and it says if the ISM does this
you should be doing this.
All history tells us is that there's an
85% correlation with a 12 month timeline.
You can still have the right idea but
mistime the situation.
So, at the moment we're going through the
idea generation phase and what I'd like to
introduce to you now is this concept of an
idea being an idea and not a trade.
So, this comes later because after the
idea generation process we have what we
call gatekeeping.
And gatekeeping is basically putting up a
barrier between your ideas and your real
capital.
And what we do in gatekeeping is basically
cleanse our ideas.
We basically take our ideas and say well
there's a good idea, I think it's a good
idea but I'm not going to put the trade on
yet because I need to time this correctly.
Now, one of the worst situations as a
trader is to have an idea, put it on
immediately, lose money because you get
stopped out on the trade where you're
losing too much money and you have to cut
the position.
So, an example of that would be buying a
stock at 100 because you think GDP is
going to go up, the earnings of the
company are going to go up in the future
and then you get stopped out or you have
to cut the position at 90.
And then the stock goes to 500.
So, what gatekeeping does is it stops good
ideas being mistimed and if you have a bad
idea, you know what, a bad idea is just a
bad idea.
So, that's where risk management comes in.
So, this concept of an idea just being an
idea and not yet a trade is very, very
important because when you're looking at
stuff like the ISM, you shouldn't
automatically just say well the ISM is
above 50 so I'm going to initiate and buy
the market now.
You still need to go through the stage of
gatekeeping and go through the stage and
have risk management and have prudent risk
management overlaid onto your strategy.
So, at the moment what we're doing is
building our world view and building our
world view means looking at all of the
economic indicators across the United
States, Eurozone and China.
Now, we're not just going to rely on the
ISM, we're going to move on now to our
next leading indicator which is within the
consumer sector which is the University of
Michigan consumer sentiment indicator.
As you saw in the presentation just
earlier, you saw that an economy is
essentially made up of two things,
businesses and consumers.
Now, when we move on to consumers, we're
going to look at consumer behaviour and
why consumer behaviour is so important.
The economy is made up of businesses and
you've already seen the ISM.
There is one more indicator that I want to
show you before we go on to consumers
though.
It's the ISM services sector because the
ISM services index doesn't represent
manufacturing companies, it represents the
service sector within the United States
which makes up 80% of the US economy.
Now, why do we not place as much
importance on ISM services as the ISM?
Well, for two reasons.
One, because the ISM data goes back to
1947 and the ISM services data only goes
back to the late 70s.
We have more business cycles, therefore
the numbers are more significant.
What we also get in terms of the ISM is
real products bought and sold.
So, ISM manufacturing is widgets.
Widgets in a warehouse that are sold as
product.
With the service sector, a service can
actually be a contract just between two
people.
So, this is why we place more importance
on manufacturing.
We'll look first at the ISM services
number and you treat this number in
exactly the same way as you treat the ISM
manufacturing number.
We'll look at that and then we're going to
move on to consumers.
So, the economy is made up of businesses
and consumers and at the moment we're
staying within businesses.
So, manufacturing and services.
And then we're going to move on to
consumers.
So, try to pick up again in the bigger
picture why we're looking at these things.
They're leading indicators, they lead GDP
and we use the stock market to make and
take positions based on our view of the
United States and the world.
So, at some point in the future we're
either correct or we're wrong.
But we're hoping always to be correct.
Well, at least 75% of the time.
Okay, so let's move on to the next video
and I'll see you on the other side.